ich wusste nicht dass das noch existiere
ich bin eigentlich schon sondern
übelster spaß eigentlich ich habe mal
kurz was vorbereitet das hier ist die
[ __ ] skala hier unten sehen wir null
hier sind so ganz normale menschen würde
ich sagen und desto höher wir gehen
desto größer ist halt eher schwach sie
werde bei jemanden und ich bin hier
würde ich sagen ich bin so ein großer
spaß die stehen der spaß die scala sogar
auf dem wort [ __ ] also ich bin halt
wirklich so'n übelster vollidiot und das
hat man auch schon in früheren videos
von mir bemerkte allerdings einige
videos von diesen früheren videos mir
irgendwann zu peinlich wurden und ich
mir dachte hey das ganze teil mehr antun
habe ich die auf privat gestellt und bis
jetzt
ich kann nicht mal reden willst jetzt
meine damen und herren haben die meisten
unter euch diese videos noch nicht
gesehen deswegen würde ich euch jetzt
ganz ganz herzlich begrüßen zu luca
schaut sich alte private von ihm privat
auf videos wir klicken hier im video
manager einfach auch privat das heißt es
werden uns nun gleich alle videos
angezeigt die ich auf privat gestellt
habe und ich sehe schon die ersten ich
werde euch jetzt genau bei jedem video
sagen warum ich auf privat gestellt habe
und wenn ich nicht mehr weiß
dann werden wir uns das video einfach
mal anschauen
du bastard das neueste video was ich auf
privat gestellt habe ist ein jahr her
ich habe seit einem jahr kein video mehr
auf privat gestellt das war welcher
youtuber bin ich eine challenge mit max
und sk das video ist sogar noch online
auf meinem kanal ich habe dieses video
nur auf privat gestellt weil ich damals
hochgeladen habe und der hd nicht
angenommen hat also high definition
quality und der hat dieses video
irgendwie komischerweise nur in
irgendeiner schrott quali angezeigt
so keine große story dahinter das
nächste video live ich spiele mit den
senioren oh mein gott das war ein
livestream zur zeit der gamescom 2017
ach du scheiße leute ach du scheiße in
diesem kompletten video haben ich und
einige omas
minecraft gespiegelt ja jetzt nach links
unten genau und jetzt wieder nach oben
genommen da sind jetzt die anderen
da musste ich eine seniorin beibringen
wie man minecraft sich blumen gebunden
aber gut dass auf jeden fall zu diesem
live ich spiele mit denen senioren
leistungen dass sie war mein erster live
stream einen tag vorher mit marx also
ich hatte ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich hatte bei der ersten wohnung weder
eine waschmaschine spülmaschine chillig
glückwunsch luca habe ich halt auch
unter genommen weil das video einfach
ein livestream war und ich will nicht
dass den leistungen auf dem kanal ist wo
ich mir keine mühe bei gegeben habe
quasi eben das nächste video ist das
dümmste video auf youtube das war ganz
lustig das habe ich nämlich deswegen
runter genauer halt man in diesem video
habe ich auf ein video reagiert was
dabei herauskommt wenn man bei google
einfach luca eingibt und da waren gegen
solche bescheuerten jugendlichen und
habe neben der scheiße gemacht und
youtube hat das video überhaupt nicht
gefeiert und hat das ich weiß nicht ob
es auch +18 gestellt haben oder
werbeeinnahmen gestrichen oder
urheberrechts kaka aber auf jeden fall
konnte es nicht weiter angezeigt werden
wie viel mühe mit dem video youtube
denkt sich hedge fonds die hier auf
jeden fall hat er nüchtern dass sie sich
einfach gesagt haben hey wir nehmen das
mal runter aber gut wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten privaten video ich bin
ironman und ich bin ja die das waren
videos in kooperation mit google play
und die wollte ich halt einfach
unternehmen weil es eine kooperation bei
und die hatte halt eine laufzeit bis
meinung ich kann es nicht warum habe ich
das denn auf privat gestellt
mein name ist herzlich willkommen
dass er war das war auch google play
sehe ich gerade engländer lesen mein
buch das ist auch eine übels bescheuerte
story und zwar dieses video kam mega gut
bei den leuten an und es war mega lustig
also ich bin halt mit meinem buch was
gerade erschienen ist bin ich halt durch
london gelaufen mit einem kumpel von mir
mit dominik porschen und wir haben
einfach engländern gesagt hey liest man
einfach ein bisschen daraus vorn wir
wollen gucken wie sich das anhört wenn
engländer deutsches buch vorlesen
[Musik]
er hat super gut geklappt es ging in
diesem video allerdings nicht nur um
engländer die mein buch gelesen haben
sondern auch visa ich denn da eigentlich
aus sondern es ging auch noch darum dass
wir auf einer filmpremiere waren und
dieser gewisse her
den kennt die wahrscheinlich aus einigen
filmen wie star wars beispielsweise ja
hier beziehungsweise seine presse tante
hier hat ihm verboten aus meinem buch
vorzulesen weil sie dachte dass ich
ihnen irgendwie schikanieren will oder
fertig machen will und dann keine ahnung
dass veröffentlichen will wersich und
danach habe ich ihn halt in meinem video
kurz vor loch genannt
und naja da wurde mir gesagt hey du bist
mal wieder lieber runter nicht dass er
irgendwie so als ob ich war leider
trotzdem cooles video was ich am
liebsten online gelassen hätte aber wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
und zwar 300 euro mein gott
ich wusste nicht dass das noch existiere
ich habe mir eine kleine 360 grad kamera
gekauft also eine kamera die alles filmt
und dann kann man in dem video so rum
ziehen und sieht alle ecken irgendwie
das war habe ich jetzt auf jeden fall
mein test davon
[Musik]
falls ihr euch fragt er das doch gar
nicht drei dm ich kann hier so ein
bisschen rum summe dass die krise so
stark auf jeden fall kannst du halt hier
alles sehen kann es hier um so mit stich
und ist doch kramers gegner ikea tüte
hier liegt eine hose und pulli hier ist
mein weg und so weiter und so fort also
das traurig habe ich noch so ein 360
grad heiß gemacht aber den will ich
nicht zeigen weil also echt fremdschäm
pur
hier haben max und ich will abu and
plays gemacht oh mein gott das habe ich
direkt wieder entfernt weil ich das so
peinlich fand mittlerweile habe ich ja
ein management ihr habt mich weiß ich
mache business
ich habe coole leute die mich halt
beraten die kampagne ist cool die würdet
ihr empfehlen zu machen und dann sage
ich die finde ich echt reisen da können
wir das machen und dies machen oder
machen wegen welche coolen kampagnen wie
beispielsweise für ea wo wir einfach im
stadion des fc köln fifa gespielt haben
das sind coole sachen allerdings war es
halt damals so lavrio habt ihr bock in
kooperation mit uns zu machen
wir achten buch voll der geile partner
voll dass großunternehmen wir machen das
aber irgendwann dachte ich mir und es
nicht ein bisschen fremd schämen und
deswegen habe ich darunter genommen hier
sind videos die patrick und ich damals
mit seiner kleinen schwester gemacht
haben die sache ist nur uns ist danach
irgendwann aufgefallen hey die schwester
von ihm war da noch voll kleiner nicht
dass sie das irgendwie nicht cool findet
deswegen haben es auch relativ zeitnah
dann auf privat gestellt hat schießen
gib ihm staffel 2 bestrafungen nein nein
nein nein wie herzlich ein echter enden
hauptsache hier hinten liegen so meine
ganzen schulsachen einfach überhaupt
nicht geordnet einfach alle übereinander
ich hab ja auf jeden fall abschließen
bekommen glaube ich das turnier sowie
ach du scheiße das weiß ich noch
arbeiten rücken
was habe ich denn früher finde scheiß
hochgeladen
anders stelle sich das heute die videos
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe mir gedacht ich habe
bisher immer nur frühere videos von mir
reagiert allerdings noch nie auf private
videos und das volk mal anschauen und
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und es
ist getan hast du keine lasten fahrer
folgte auf instagram